Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow of death,
I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, good morning, church family.
My name is Jimmy Quinn and I'm on staff here as our connections pastor. And so,
like Scott said, if you're new here, welcome. Uh, so glad you're here,
love to meet you after the service, uh, I'll kind of probably be in this area,
so come by and say hi. Or if you want,
you can go out those doors into the construction zone. Big sign.
Amy is out there. She'd love to meet you too. But, uh, as we get started,
I wanna tell you guys a story. Now, this story's a little bit graphic, uh,
but it's PG graphic. And so, uh,
I'm gonna use some strategic words as I share today,
but there were two men who were visiting a small city in the Middle East.
And when they arrived, uh, they were welcomed into the house of another man.
And word got around that, uh, these guests were there. And so the people,
all of them,
young and old of the town rallied together to ambush these
visitors. The story goes on that the men circled the house,
the men circled the house and demanded that they get to know these
men and have relations with them.
So my wife and I had the privilege of going to Israel a couple weeks back,
and we were near the city or the cities where this happened.
Those cities are Sodom and Gomorrah.
And you can read more about this story in Genesis 18 and 19,
but how does that story end? Well,
God spared the homeowner and the visitors and the family from these wicked
men, but then he rained down fire and sulfur,
and these two cities have never been rebuilt again,
and they won't be rebuilt again because of God's justice towards the wicked.
So we'll be in Psalm 58 today as we continue this summer going
chapter by chapter for different psalms.
And so if you were here the last two weeks, you've heard, um,
from Phil and Brandon, um, who did a great job.
And in the next two weeks you'll hear from our boy Brent McCoy and
Ryan Whitaker, who's one of my favorites in these five psalms.
The last two, this one, and these next two are all similar.
They're all connected in some way. Um, but Psalm 58 is a little bit different.
It's an imprecatory psalm.
Now an imprecatory psalm is one in which the author calls down,
uh, destruction a curse or judgment onto his enemies.
And so, um, they're not uncontrolled outbursts or angers of, uh,
of expression or personal vengeance like they may seem.
And so our author of our psalm today is David,
and he's calling out to God because the injustices of corrupt leaders around
him,
he describes him as wicked a term given to people who don't fear honor
or obey God.
So today we'll talk about corrupt leaders and as I read this psalm a couple
weeks month back, I was like, oh boy, what are they setting me up for here?
You know, this seems like a slippery slope given our climate,
but the more that I've studied, uh, got help from, uh,
our community group discussion guide and friends, and, uh,
there's a book Christ-Centered Ex uh, exposition that's really been helpful.
The more I believe, uh,
the David's central point that he's trying to get us to understand is that
true believers of the gospel ought to be enraged at injustices
driving us to our needs and prayer,
true believers of the gospel ought to be enraged at injustices driving us
to our knees in prayer. So before we read the text in Psalm 58,
lemme pray for us, God,
as we open up your word to us.
I I pray for the, the hearers of your word that they, they hear from you,
not from me. Um, they see your justice,
but they also see your mercy and your love and your forgiveness and your grace.
Uh, be with us today as we, um, uh, study your word. It's in your name we pray.
Amen. Psalm 58
says this. It says, do you
decree what is right? Oh God's,
do you judge the children of man uprightly? No.
In your hearts, you devise wrongs in your hands,
deal out violence on the earth. The wicked are estranged from the womb.
They go astray from birth speaking lies.
They have venom like the venom of a serpent,
like the death adder that stops its ears.
So it does not hear the voice of charmers or cunning enchanter,
oh God, break the teeth in their mouth,
tear out their fangs of young lions. Oh Lord,
let them vanish like water that runs away when he aims his arrows.
Let them be blunted.
Let them be like the snail that's dissolved in slime like the stillborn child
who never sees the sun sooner than your pots can feel the heat of thorns,
whether green or lays. May he be swept away.
The righteous will rejoice when he sees vengeance.
He will bathe his feet in the blood of the wicked and mankind will say,
surely there is a reward for righteousness.
Surely there is a God who judges the earth in all God's people said,
amen. Right. What a fun passage.
So we get to talk about venom of snakes and,
and snake charmers and fangs of lions.
We get to talk about slime kids. How do we feel about slime
parents? How do you feel about slime? Yeah,
I'm with you. Um, and then we gotta talk about bathing in blood. And so,
um, you guys wanna walk through this text and see what it means. Let's do it.
Let's begin.
So we don't really know what's for what's going on in David's life for certain,
but based off the similarities of these five psalms together,
we could assume that David is writing this song as a result of King
Saul. Saul was the king at the time, and he was chasing after David,
uh, because he was angry and feared, uh, he was a threat to his throne.
So presumably David is calling out to God about the injustices of Saul.
And so the structure of our psalm today,
Psalm 50 eight's really gonna help with us, uh,
with our main points and our three subpoints,
which the main point is true. Believers of the gospel ought to be enraged.
Injustices driving us to our knees and prayer, it should frustrate us.
And then our first point that we see in verses one through five is that David
rebukes the wicked David rebukes the wicked.
So he starts off with a question which he quickly answers. Now,
I love my wife and she doesn't do this. Um,
and and maybe your wives or husbands don't do this either way,
but imagine your spouse saying, honey, did you take out the trash?
And before you could even answer, um, he or she responded back, no you didn't.
Well, that's kind of what's happening here.
David asked the question and he responds, infa in emphatically no,
in your heart you devise wrong.
What he's saying here is that it's a premeditated evil that it was planned out.
He then goes on to say that the wicked are estranged from the womb.
I wanna pause here and I wanna expound a little bit about what that could mean.
How can a person go astray from birth?
David in Psalm 51 recognizes this of himself when he says that he was born
with sin. Now,
the Bible clearly teaches that children are sinners.
Can I get an amen from a mom of a three year old? Right?
We are not born innocent, only later to become sinners.
Being sinful from birth means that our hearts are inclined towards sin
prior to any actual sins happening.
This inner sinfulness is the root in this source of all actual sins.
So to get technical, this is called depravity. And anytime I hear depravity,
I go back to Genesis chapter five, verse three.
So follow with me here in Genesis chapter one and two,
God created the heavens and the earth, right?
And he created man and woman and he created Adam in his own
likeness, right? Well, in Genesis five, verse three,
which is after Adam and Eve were removed,
removed from the presence of God in the garden, because they're a sin,
we see that Adam fathered a son in his likeness.
And so what's his likeness? Well, his likeness is of a sinful man.
So that kind of sounds like a bummer of a deal for us, right?
That before we have a chance to not sin,
we are already inclined to sin.
But I think this is where we see the beauty of the gospel through one man's
sin enter the world, but through another man, the second Adam, we see Christ.
Romans chapter five, verses 12 through 21 really explains this well.
And so I wanna read part of it. It's kind of a lot.
Paul does a great job of explaining it. It goes into a lot of detail.
But I wanna read verse 12 and then skip down to verse 17. It says this,
therefore, just as sin came in through the world, through one man and death,
through sin, so death spread to all men, because all sin, verse 17,
for if because of one man's trespasses, death reign through that one man,
much more will those who receive the abundance of grace and the free gift of
righteousness reign in life through one man Jesus Christ. Therefore,
as one trespass led to the condemnation for all men.
So one act of righteousness leads to the justification and life for all men.
For as by one man's disobedience, the many were made sinners.
So by one man's obedience, the many were made righteous.
Now the law came to increase the trespass,
but where sin increased grace abounded all the more so that as
death as sin reigned in death,
grace also might reign through the righteousness leading to eternal life through
Jesus Christ, our Lord. Do you guys see the beauty in that?
Because of our sin through Adam, we were prescribed death.
And because of our sin, because of your sin, and because of my sin,
we were separated from God. But then Romans tells us, but God,
through his amazing grace, we can have eternal life, not eternal death.
So Jesus reversed the sin, reversed the curse of sin,
reversed the death so that we can receive this free gift of life.
All hell king Jesus, right? Praise God for king Jesus.
So back to Psalm 58, David, uh, talking about their depravity,
then he compares the effectiveness of these wicked abusers to the venom of
snakes.
These influencers were poisoning those entrusted to their care
and it makes David angry. Now, this is where it gets tricky.
Friends, I think the psalm is telling us that when we see injustices,
it should make us angry. For example,
think of a child being abused,
that should make you angry.
Or maybe as someone with special needs being bullied,
that should make us angry.
Or a senior adult being conned and then neglected,
or kids being exposed to all sorts of evil before they even uh,
should be exposed to things like that.
Things like this and many others should make us angry Christian.
And then in verse five,
we see the wording about charmers and cunning enchanters.
That means that these wicked people are just turning a deaf ear to any sort of
logic or voice of reason or persuasion.
They don't care to listen.
So what do we do with verses like this? Well,
I think we have an obligation to advocate for the relief of those who are
victims of oppression.
But with that obligation and must be seasoned with salt,
we must always advocate through the lens of the gospel and with the character of
Christ. You'll miss the point of today if you hear me promote any kind of, uh,
of an upheaval. And before we rush off to start, uh,
throwing stones and casting out people's abuse,
we must first remember our sin and the incredible gift of God's mercy for us.
So our first point in Psalm 58, verses one through five,
we see that David rebukes the wicked and our second point in the text
verses six through nine, where I think it gets fun, uh,
real fun part of the text we see David requesting for justice,
David requests for justice. So let me ask you a rhetorical question.
If true believers of Jesus are to oppose,
be frustrated by and enraged at justice at injustices like we just saw,
how much good can you do on your own to stifle these wicked
people in the world? Honestly, you can probably drum up, uh,
some, some helpers and strive to make a dent through activism and protests,
which I'm not saying is wrong at all. But what did David do?
What was his response to these justices?
I'd like to offer a more effective strategy than activism and protest.
And that's prayer.
David calls out to God and he does so by using several
metaphors. So he says, God, would you break their?
And so we're just gonna walk through these. They're kind of fun. So,
so God would you break their teeth and tear out their fangs?
So David is asking that these evil people keep from communicating.
And it's important to note here that David doesn't think these wicked
influencers are are cool little cats and kittens,
but rather wild and untamed beasts.
He's asking for a dentist.
Then David request that they be like an evaporating water here today
and gone tomorrow. The third metaphor that their arrows be blunted.
David is essentially asking for his enemies to have Nerf guns.
Who wants to have a Nerf gun war? That sounds kind of fun.
And then my fourth or the fourth analogy metaphor that we see,
uh, is that of a, a snail dissolved in slime.
Some of your versions may say slug.
Has anyone ever poured salt on a slug or a slime?
Okay, good. I was like, surely somebody has. I'm not the only one. Well,
what happens to that? Well, they dissolve,
they turn gooey and dead. And so, uh, it's kind of fun.
You should try it sometime. But then next,
the fifth thing is that God not even let evil people be born.
He's asking that their eyes never see the sun.
And then the final request, he uses a campfire analogy.
So imagine you're going camping and, and you catch some food.
Maybe you catch some fish for a fish fry, or maybe you catch a chicken. I,
I don't know what you catch, but imagine putting it a pot of water and,
and you go to cook it and you get the,
the sticks all kindled and, and it's gonna be a good fish fry.
And then some of our Oklahoma 80 mile an hour winds come sweeping down the plane
and it puts out your fire.
And so now you're left with sushi or uncooked chicken.
Neither one are very good, but what David is asking for
is that God render them useless and do so quickly.
So to summarize these six curses that David is asking God for about the wicked
is that they be mute, evaporated, pointless, dissolved,
not even born and useless. That's what David's asking for.
Should believers pray like this?
The psalmist appears driven by outrage that these leaders exist at all.
His desire for their end seems violent.
One theologian says it this way about praying such violent prayers. He says,
it prompts us to question whether an impassioned curse of tyrants is better
or worse than a shrug of shoulders or diplomatic silence.
He's saying that passivity is worse.
The same theologian shares the idea that when Jesus seemed to opt for this
bolder approach in the New Testament, in Matthew 23, he lists out a,
a series of curses to the scribes and Pharisees, when he says, woe to you,
you scribes, you, Pharisees, you hypocrites.
So these lead in are followed by some of Jesus's most strongest and most damning
words in all the New Testament. And while none of us are Jesus,
and while our engagement with bad people must be intended to overcome evil with
good,
our Lord did seem to affirm this practice that the psalmist is crying out for,
that God would bring an end to malicious leaders.
That's what we see. So David requests for justice.
And then in the final verse,
we see David rejoicing David rejoices for righteousness.
And why? Because he knows how the story ends.
So imagine David singing the song, I know how the story ends,
and when he gets to this part of the psalm, he's like, yeah,
and we're about to sing that song here in a minute and Lindsay's gonna lead us
through that. But David knows how the story ends.
He knows that God will respond to the prayers of a ch of his children when we
cry out to him. God doesn't change.
He has always been a just God and he will always be a just God.
He's been clear about that all along. And the prophet Isaiah says in chapter 24,
verse 21,
that there will be a day when God will impose his full and complete judgment on
the wicked. And at that time, those who are in Christ will celebrate justice.
David knows how the story ends.
Verse 10 and 11, the righteous will rejoice when he sees the vengeance.
He will bathe his feet in the blood of the wicked verse ten's kind of
confusing, why will the righteous bathe in blood?
Sounds kind of grotesque and maybe I could be convinced
that there's some benefits to this mud bath that some of you guys partake in,
you know, exfoliating things and sheen and all that kinda stuff.
But a mud bath seems a little different to me. And so it's kind of a,
a yucky expression in my opinion. But the one theologian says it this way,
this is an expression of a traditional near Eastern way of
describing the utter defeat of an enemy.
So we're not looking at some twisted grim foot washing ceremony, but as victors,
they weighed through the blood leftover from the carnage of battle.
So you may have heard the analogy bloodbath in maybe a sporting
event. Uh, big time sporting events,
important sporting events like King of the Beach. Uh,
for those of you that don't know,
our church is about to have a king of the beach volleyball tournament beginning
today.
And I just wanna warn my opponents that they may be in for a blood bath because
I'm feeling pretty good today. Anyway, back to the text.
Um, this blood bath sounds morbid and gruesome,
and we may be attempted to shy away from this, or at least I am,
but it makes complete sense in light of a larger,
the larger biblical picture of God's righteousness.
He wants us to anticipate a day when he will make right all things that are
wrong in this world.
And if you wanna know more about how this final battle will look like,
or some of the scenes flip to Revelation 14 or 19,
Isaiah 63, and the scene here in Psalm 58 will seem,
will kind of pale in comparison to those. Verse 11,
mankind will say, surely there is a reward for righteousness.
Surely there is a God who judges the earth. What is this reward?
What is it? What's our reward for righteousness? Well,
according to Deuteronomy 28,
our reward is that we'll be blessed and it lists a bunch of ways that we'll be
blessed.
But also verse 11 indicates that people will not be left to
the decisions of unjust judges forever.
One day friends,
one day Christ is gonna come back and he will make all things
wrong, all things right that are wrong in our world.
And if you're frustrated with the world, well,
let me give you a sneak peek.
It's gonna get worse until Christ comes back.
But one day Jesus is gonna come back and he's gonna make right
all things that are wrong. I'm encouraged by Philippians two,
verse five through 11, when Paul's writing, he says,
have this mind among yourselves, which is yours in Christ Jesus.
Who though was in the form of God,
did not count equality with God a thing to be grasp.
But he emptied himself by taking the form of a servant,
being born in the likeness of men and being found in human form.
He humbled himself by becoming obedient to the point of death,
even death on the cross. Therefore,
God has highly exalted him and bestowed upon him the name that is above every
name, so that at the name of Jesus,
every knee should bow in heaven and on earth and under the earth.
And every tongue will confess that Jesus Christ is Lord to the glory of God
the Father. So I read this passage for a couple reasons. One,
every knee will bow in heaven and on earth and under the earth.
And every tongue will confess that Jesus Christ is Lord.
Every person who has ever lived, every principality,
every person who has influence will know that Jesus Christ is Lord forever.
And they will have to make an accountability to our king for their decisions.
Justice will be here soon.
But the second reason I read this passage is not only because we see victory
over these wicked people, but we see Christ,
we can be quick to move past verse 11 and miss something really big.
So I was trying to think of, of a good example of people who have been, uh,
abused or, or oppressed or mistreated.
And you guys can probably guess where I'm going. But Jesus, our king,
our Lord, he was oppressed, he was beaten,
he was spat on. He had a spear in his side.
His hands were nailed to across his feet were nailed to across.
There was a crown of thorns on his head.
He's king of kings, lord of lords.
And Paul tells us in Philippians that he took on the form of a servant.
The main point that of our texts today is true believers ought to be enraged at
injustices.
And the worst injustice of them all is the fact that Jesus Christ gave up heaven
on earth.
He left heaven to come and live a perfect sinless life so that you
and I could be made right before our king. And that's not fair.
If we think about it,
Paul tells us in Romans that Christ gave up his life because of his great love
for us.
You and I deserve a punishment for your premeditated sins.
You and I deserve a consequence for those routine sins that you still do.
Our ugly and grievous mistakes that we made on Thursday,
those that we're gonna make on Wednesday all deserve a consequence.
But Jesus paid that consequence for us all. Helling Jesus, right?
Friends,
we were the wicked with the teeth and the slime and the slug and uh,
the evaporated water. We were wicked. But through Christ,
through his righteousness, we have been made right?
We've been made clean
Some, some applications to this first, uh, David Rebukes,
the wicked David requests for justice.
And then he rejoices because he knows how the story is.
So what do we do with a text like this today?
One five suggestions for us.
Be angry at sin.
Be more angry at sin than the sinner because the reality,
like we just talked about,
you and I are sinners to and in need of a savior.
And if you haven't realized your need for a savior and the beauty of God's
amazing grace, we would love to talk with you. In fact, after this service,
when we're done, we're gonna have people here in the front and on the sides.
And we would love to just pray with you. It doesn't have to be prayer about, uh,
your spiritual state. It could be, uh,
a job situation that you want prayer for or a family member who needs help. Uh,
that's sick. You know, whatever it might be.
We would love to be a praying people,
but your sin, your wickedness deserves a consequence.
And Jesus paid that consequence and an unfair debt for you and for me.
And in return for that payment,
the Bible calls us to live a surrendered life to our Lord
also in scripture. Point number two,
with a surrendered life that should look like when we encounter people who are
full of sin, who aren't like us.
I think we, we should go to the the greatest commandment.
All four gospel tells us this in some ways, tells us to,
tells us to love the Lord your God, with all of our heart, soul, mind,
and strength, and to love our neighbors as ourself a surrendered life,
one that is angry at sin will seek to love God and love people.
So point number application. Number two, love God and love people,
even sin filled people.
All sorts of people that come to your mind when you think of wickedness.
We're called to love those people. Number three,
pray for the repentance of our leaders. When Jesus was on the cross,
his body was bleeding. He cries out. Father,
forgive them for they don't know what they're doing.
So pray for the salvation of our leaders.
Pray for those that have influence.
But the Psalm would kind of suggest to us that if those people do not
submit their lives to God,
that then we are to pray a different kind of prayer.
A prayer for drastic change.
The Psalm assumes that these wicked rulers would not repent and would not seek
justice. And these violent people are just waiting to pounce on their pray.
So the psalmist is saying, Lord, bring your justice swiftly.
And maybe that should be our prayer too. Four,
I think there's an application here to care for the oppressed.
When you see abuse happening, call it out. And one of the ways,
and there's many, we could probably do a whole sermon on this,
but one of the ways that we can care for those being exploited is to make
aware, however that looks like in your sphere,
but make aware of the injustices for the purpose of pointing people to
Jesus. Not just because they disagree, you disagree with them,
but for the purpose of pointing them to Jesus.
And lastly, an important reminder here.
It's not our responsibility to bring justice, it's God's.
David's only action in this psalm is to cry out to God
because God is the sovereign one. He doesn't change.
We know how the story ends.
True believers of the gospel ought to be enraged at injustices
driving us to our niece in prayer.